اعلنت روسيا احباط مسامته هجوما ارهابيا
اوكرانيا بطائرتين مسيرتين على الكرملين
واكدت ان الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين لم يكن
موجودا لحظه وقوعه وانها تحتفظ بحق الرد
عليه من ناحيته نفى الرئيس الاوكراني
بولودي مرزلينسكي اي صله لبلاده بالهجوم
واتهم نظيره الروسي بافتعاله بينما قالت
واشنطن انها بصدد التحقق من صحه حديث
موسكو عن الهجوم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما حقيقه وحيثيات
اتهام موسكو كييف بمحاوله اغتيال الرئيس
بوتين عبر استهداف الكريم
وما طبيعه الرد الذي لمحت الى عزمها
الاقدام عليه وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان تستقبل
موسكو نفيه كييف مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم وكيف
تنظر واشنطن وحلفائها الغربيون لهذا
التطور الجديد في اطار الصراع بين روسيا
والغرب وما الانعكاسات المحتمله لهذا
الحادث على مسار الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا في ضوء اعلان الجانب الروسي
احتفاضه بحق الرد
[موسيقى]
لم يكن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
موجودا في الكرملين ولم يصب بالتالي باي
اذاء بحسب موسكو نتيجه ما تقول انه هجوم
ارهابي اوكراني نفذته طائرتان مسيرتان على
اليوم روسيا التي تقول انها احبطت ذلك
الهجوم وانها اكتشفت مسيره ثالثه في ضواحي
موسكو اكدت احتفاظها بحق الرد عليه في
الزمان والمكان الذين تختارهما تلميح وجد
بعض التفسير في تصريحات بعضها لمسؤولين
رافعي المستوى في مجلس الدوما راوا في
الهجوم سببا مباشرا للحرب وتصفيه القياده
السياسيه الاوكرانيه وهو منحا ذهب اليه
ايضا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
الذي قال ان الهجوم على الكرملين لا يدع
امام روسيا خيارا سوى ما سماه التخلص من
الرئيس الاوكراني
في كييف
اوكرانيا التي سارع مسؤول رفيع في رئاستها
الى نفي علاقه بلاده بهجوم الكريم بل وراء
فيه مؤشرا علنيه روسيه مبيته لشن مساماه
هجوما ارهابيا واسعا على بلاده في فتره
مقبله عادت على لسان الرئيس فولودي
مرزيلينسكي تاكيد عدم صلاتها بالهجوم
لا نهاجم بوتين ولا موسكو نحارب على ارضنا
وندافع عنها لا نملك كما تعلمون اسلحه
كافيه لتنفيذ هذه الهجمات لذلك لا
نستخدمها في اي مكان ولا نسمح لانفسنا
بهدرها لم نهاجم سنترك الامر للقضاء
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو
الكزامدر غورنوف الاستاذ في معهد موسكو
للصحافه الدوليه من واشنطن ينضم الينا
الدكتور دونالدز جنسا الدبلوماسي الامريكي
السابق في موسكو ومن عمان معنا اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
مرحبا بكم جميعا سنبدا معك
بمحاوله اغتيال الرئيس الروسي وكياف تنفي
من نصدق
بامكانكم ان تصدقوا
اي شخص لم يسبق له الكذب اليوم السيد
ديلينسكي وهو في مؤتمره الذي زاره مفاجاه
لم يدعوه الى هناك اي شخص جاء بطائره
امريكيه عسكريه واعلن ان اوكرانيا لم تقم
بهذه الهجمات بالمسيرات على
انه يحاول تحرير اراضي وانه لا يقوم بقصف
اي اراضي روسيا نقطه اخر السطر اريد ان
اذكر الهجمات الارهابيه التي حدثت ووقعت
في موسكو حيث قتلت داريا
ثم قتل الصحفي الروسي المعروف وهناك كان
قد اعتقل المسؤولين عن العمليه
وقدموا اعترافات
بان كيف هي من نظمت لهذا واذكر ان الهجمات
ضد الجسر في القرم ايضا والهجمات ايضا
مستمره على مختلف المواقع السكانيه في
الضواحي بقرب الحدود الاوكرانيه
ولا اذكر هنا الهجمات على
القرمم
وما هو غير ذلك اذا زلينسكي
لا يجب تصديقه
واما بالنسبه للادعاء ان روسيا من قامت
بهذه الهجمات او ان ما قالوه في واشنطن ان
روسيا هي من دمرت خطوط الغاز وكلها
ادعاءات مضحكه وسخيفه لكن سيد اليكساندر
هل تمتلك موسكو ادله مقنعه
لاقناع العالم بهذا الاتهام الكبير يعني
هي تتهم امتياز بانها تحاول اغتيال بوتين
ان اقول ان روسيا لن تحاول ان تثبت اي شيء
ان روسيا تقوم باداره حرب
رده الفعل ستكون هي الاثبات الحقيقي انا
لا اعتقد انه هناك من الضروره ان نثبت اي
شيء هنا
اذا كنت تسالي رايي الخاص فانا لا اعتقد
ان
هذه محاوله
اغتيال او محاوله عقلانيه من قبل اداره
لانه اولا الهجمه كانت ليلا عندما يكون من
الواضح بالنسبه 99% ان بوتين غير متواجد
في مكتبه حيث يعمل لديه في هذا المبنى شق
يبات بها احيانا ولكن هذا نادر جدا الشيء
الثاني
انا
لم ارى ان في هذه المسيرات شواحن قويه من
نوع قرده التي
من الممكن
ان تحمل ما يزيد عن كيلو جرام من
المتفجرات
فهذا
لا يؤثر على مبنى بهذا الحجم مثل مبنى
الكرملين
ولا يؤدي الى
ايزاندر سنتحدث مع اللواء فايز دواري في
الجانب العسكري من هذه من هذا الهجوم
اليوم لكن دعنا نذهب الى السيد دونلد جنسن
ضيفنا
من الولايات المتحده
وتقييمه تقييمك دكتور دونات جونسون لهذا
الهجوم في ضوء الاتهام الروسي والنفي
الاوكراني
ان روسيا لا تمتلك هو اي ادله هي تتهم على
حسب اساسي دعايه روسيه طويله لالقاء اللوم
على اوكرانيا حول كل شيء اعتقد ان بيان
وتعليقات زيد رئيس
مناسبه روسيا خرقت القانون الدولي هو افضل
مكان للرئيس بوتين هو ان ياخذ على
المحاكمه في لهاي لكن في حقيقه الامر اريد
ان اسال صديقي روسي كيف ستشعر اذا ما قمتم
كان هنالك قصف للشقق السكنيه والعيادات في
كيف كيف تشعرون اذا منقلبت الحال تعتقدون
ان كي يبقى قامت بهذا الامر بصراحه الامر
كيف لا تمتلك اطقم سيارات تصل الى هذا
المدى هل روسيا قامت بهذا الامر ربما هي
روسيا تحاول ان تكسب بعض الوقت وان تكون
هنالك استفز شعوري العام لكن ايضا هنالك
احتماليه كما تحدث زميلي الروسي انه رب
العوده الى
اغتيال دوقنا كان هنالك دليل واضح ادله
ظرفيه ان هنالك ربما نشاطات داخل روسيا
ربما هي تكون اكثر فعاله من اي وقت مضى
وربما هو هذا الجواب لكن كما قلت روسيا
ليس لديها اي دليل انك يبقى مت بهذا الامر
ولا كيف نمتلك الامكانها تعتقد ان هنالك
طرف اخر وساضيف ايضا انه ربما
ليس على ان يقوم باطلاق النار على مواطنيه
او ان يقوم بالاستفزاز لكن السماح لمسيرات
بان تضرب الكرملين هو امر مهين جدا للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه وقد تعرضت للاهانه خلال
الاشهر الماضيه الامر مذل جدا ولا اعتقد
ان هذا الامر قد يكون
هذا ايضا كما قلت قد يكون هنالك طرف اخر
وراء هذا الامر لكن علينا ان ننتظر لنرى
تكشف المزيد من الادله اللواء فايز على
الصعيد العسكري هل يمكن من خلال هذه
العمليه التدليل على من يقف وراءها السيد
دون جونسون يقول كياف لا تمتلك الامكانات
وضيفنا من موسكو يؤكد ان كياف هي من ارسل
هذه المسيرات
عسكريا ما الذي يمكن ان نستخلص
يعني نحن الان امام ثلاثه احتمالات لكن لا
تزال المعلومات شحيحه
بناء على التصريحات من الجانب الاوكراني
والجانب الروسي اضعها في ثلاثه احتمالات
الاحتمال الاول نتبنى وجهه النظر الروسيه
ان اوكرانيا هي المسؤوله الان بالنسبه
لحجم الطائره طائره صغيره لا يمكن لها ان
تسير مئات الكلوترات هذا الحجم من
الطائرات لا يعني لا يمكن ان يطلق لانه
حتى هذه اللحظه لوح الطائره غير معروف نحن
يعني نتحدث عن افتراضات ولا نملك الحقائق
لو نوع الطائره الثالثه تم الكشف عن نوعها
سنتحدث ما هي امكانات الطائره اذا نحن
نتحدث عن شيء غير معروف بالتالي
مراسل الجزيره تحدث اكثر من طائرات صغيره
وبالتالي ابطال الصغيره لا تستطيع ان تطير
مسافه من اكثر من 500 كيلو متر وكيف طارت
كل هذه ولم يتم اكتشاف هذه الاحتمال الاول
الشطر الاول من الاحتمال الاول الشطر
الثاني هل
اوكرانيا نفذت العمل من خلال جماعات لها
تعمل في داخل الارض الروسيه وخاصه ان هذه
الطائرات يمكن الحصول عليها بسوء بسهوله
يبقى هذا الاحتمال قيد البحث والتحقق بعد
الكشف على الطائره ناتي الان الى الخيار
الرئيسي الثاني وهو الاتهام الاوكراني
لروسيا بان روسيا هي من تقف وراء هذا
الحدث الان تم عرض الفيديو
لاحظنا انا
كمختص في هذا الشان
شاهدنا الطائره
تتحرك باتجاه القبه
وتفجرت في اللحظه الاولى كنت اعتقد انها
اصابت الهدف بعد التحقق تبين انها لم تصب
الهدف ولم تصب الساريه ولم تصيب العلم
والاهم لم الاحظ اي صاروخ ينطلق من الارض
اذا الان اسقاطها لم يتم بدفاعات جويه
تقليديه لانه كان يجب ان نلاحظ ان هناك
صاروخ قادم وخاصه ان الامر خطير جدا ويجب
ان تكون المعلومه موثقه اذا كيف سقطت
الان اذا الاتهام الاوكراني قائم يمكن
روسيا ان تسقطها
بعده طرق اذا كانت روسيه الطريقه الاولى
بالليزر لانه لم اشاهد شيء وبالتالي يمكن
اسقاطها بالليزر يمكن اسقاطها بنوع الفيوز
وهناك اكثر من نوع وهذا كلام يعني اسف هو
كلام فني الفيوز التقاربي هذا الفيوز
يعتمد على الارتفاع والمسافه
والنقطه التي يجب ان ينفجر بها تلقائيا هل
هذه الطائره روسيه وتم تفجيرها بناء على
تصميم معين للفيوز هذا
كتخصص وارد جدا يبقى الاحتمال الثالث ان
جماعات كما كانت الاتهام كما كان الاتهام
من قبل الجانب الاوكراني ان جماعات
المقاومه الوطنيه لكن القول الفصل يكون في
الاتي
السؤال الاهم انا كمحلل وباحث في هذا
الامر اقول من هو المستفيد من هذا الحدث
هل اوكرانيا مستفيده انا هنا لا ادافع عن
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا قطعا هي الجانب الخاسر
لان الرد سيكون قاسي والرد قد ينال
الدائره السياسيه فاذا مثلا اسال به ضيفنا
من موسكو
اليكساندر قلت ان روسيا لن تحاول ان تثبت
اي شيء وانا ردت الفعل ستكون هي الاثبات
الحقيقي ما نوع رده الفعل التي يمكن ان
نتوقعها اذا هكذا فعل
قصيرين اذا سمحت لي على ما قاله زملاء
اولا ان الصواريخ المضاده الجويه
لا تستخدم
بمضاد كمضادات للمسيارات بل تستخدم
المضادات الالكترونيه لذلك ليس هناك
صواريخ كان ممكن ان تواجه هذه المسيره
الزميل من واشنطن تحدث عن الدلائل اذا كان
يريد اي دلائل فانا استطيع ان اقدم له
افضل
دليل امريكي وانجليز
عندما حاولوا اثبات ان روسيا من كانت
مسؤوله عن اغتيال شخص في لندن
وما كان لديهم الا
دليل واضح
انا اتفق ان
المسيره انطلقت من اراضي روسيه وليس
اوكرانيه وربما من بعض المباني المجيره
للكرملين هناك الكثير من الفنادق العاليه
وكان من الممكن اطلاق المسيرات من هناك او
من اي مبنى قريب ولكن لا تنسوا ان موسكو
وضواحيها
وصلت لها الكثير من المسيرات الاوكرانيه
لضواحي موسكو اما بالنسبه
الرئيس السابق لروسيا قال انه من المهم ان
نقتل جيرنسكي جزاء على ما قام به
والكثيرين من ممثلين البرلمان الروسي
قالوا اننا علينا ان
ندمر الشارع حيث
مركز الاداره الحكوميه في كييف اي ان ندمر
المبنى الاداري للرئاسه الاوكرانيه وان
ندمر مبنى الوزارات والبرلمان وروسيا
تستطيع ان تفعل هذا بكل سهيله ولدينا
صواريخ كليبر الذي لا يستطيع احد ان يقف
ضدها والمنظومه المضاده
للدفاع الجوي لا تستطيع تدميرها وممكن ان
ندمر اي مبنى من هذه المباني هل ستقوم
روسيا بهذا انا لست متاكد من هذا لانه اذا
كانت روسيا تريد هذا لقامت به منذ فتره
لان اوكرانيا تخطت جميع الخطوط الحمراء
سابقا وقامت هذا مره ومره
والان تقوم بهذه الهجمه التي تعتبر ضغطا
نفسيا على الكرملين وكيف يريدون هذه رده
الفعل بالذات
سيد الكسندر كورنوف الرد الامريكي على ما
تقول موسكو انه هجوم على الكريم عبر عنه
وزير الخارجيه الذي قال انه اطلع على
تقارير الخاصه بذلك الهجوم وانه لا يستطيع
تاكيد صحتها في مؤتمر صحفي ان واشنطن تاخذ
كل ما يصدر عن الكرملين بقدر كبير من الشك
وانها ستنتظر ظهور الحقائق قبل تعليق على
الروايه الروسيه اعود الى
الاحتمالين يعني هنا واضح ان هناك تشكيك
في الموقف الروسي ولكن ايضا تريث
امريكي قبل اتخاذ موقف في الاحتمالين ما
سيكون عليه حقيقه الموقف الامريكي في حال
كان هذا الهجوم تقف وراء روسيا ام في حال
ايضا كانت تقف وراءه اوكرانيا ما هو حقيقه
الموقف الامريكي من ذلك باعتقادك
هذا سؤالا وجيه لها اعتقد قد سيكون هنالك
بالتاكيد موقف رسمي امريكي اعلنوا من قبل
مسؤولا امريكي واعتقد انه لن يكون هنالك
دليل كافي
لمزاعم الرؤوس كما قال زميلي ان هذه
المسيرات صغيره لكنني اريد ان اركز على
نقطه هام هذا ذكرني بعض الشيء حول
مساله
ساحه الحمراء في التسعينيات هذا قوض الثقه
لدى
الناس الروسيين الناس العاديين هذه لم
تحصل المره الاولى بامكاننا ان ننظر الى
اغتيال دقنه الرصيف الماضيه اعتقد انه
للمره الاولى نرى هنالك الكثير من الشكوك
لدى الروس من ان الكرمليون بامكانه ان يفي
بوعوده في حمايه الشعب الروسي انا اشاهد
دكتور لو سمحت يعني حتى نختصر ونستفيد من
الوقت ومن وجودك معنا حدثني لو سمحت عن
الموقف الامريكي ما الذي يمكن ان يكون
عليه هذا الموقف في الاحتمالين ان كانت
روسيا تقف وراء هذا الهجوم او ان كانت
اوكرانيا ايضا تقف وراءه
لن يكون هنالك موقف لانه لا يمكن اثبات من
قام بماذا
الناس ربما سيتمون الى استنتاجات خاصه
اعتقد ان واشنطن قد من المحتمل ان تصدق
تعليقات من ان اوكرانيا ليس لها علاقه
بهذا الامر وهنالك الادله الغير مكتمله
تقترح ان الاوكرانين ليس لهم اي علاقه
بهذا الامر بالتالي اترك الكثير من
الاسئله المفتوحه حول ما حدث وهذا امر
علينا ان نحققه بشكل اضافي وبصراحه لن
اكون متفاجئ اذا ما كان هنالك هجمات
ارهابيه اضافيه تاتي من اماكن مختلفه خلال
الاسابيع القادمه لكنها لن تاتي من
اوكرانيا لانهم كما ذكروا اليوم هم لا
يقوموا بمهاجمه روسيا هم يدافعوا عن
اوكرانيا وبوتين يجب ان يكون مكانه في
المحكمه في لها ولا يتم اغتياله والاسلحه
التي تم استخدامها يوم امس لم تكن كافيه
لانه حسب كل التقارير الاعلاميه وكما ذكر
زميلي الروسي فان الرئيس الرو ياخذ الوقت
الكثير في الكرمله بالتالي هذا شيء اخر
شيء اخر يختلف عما ذكرته الحكومه الروسيه
وعلينا ان ننتظر ونرى اذا ما كان هنالك
تكشف لادله حاسمه اضافيه على كل اريد ان
الفت الى هذا الخبر العاجل البيت الابيض
يقول انه من السابق لاوانه القول ان روسيا
ستستخدم حادثه الكريم ذريعه لمزيد من
الاستفزازات في اوكرانيا لواء فايز
الان روسيا تتوعد برد على هذا الهجوم في
المكان والزمان المناسبين يتحدث ضيفنا
السيد الكسندر من موسكو عن تصريحات
للمسؤولين الروسي يتحدثون عن ربما الذهب
نحو محاوله اغتيال زيلينسكي تدمير الشارع
حيث مركز الاداره السياسيه في اوكرانيا ما
الذي يمكن ان تكون عليه طبيعه الرد الروسي
الرد متوقع وقريب
والرد سيكون
مماثل
لضربه جسر كيرش جسر القرم ولكن على نطاق
اوسع سيشمل ثلاثه دوائر من الاهداف
اولا البعد او الاهداف السياسيه بغض النظر
سواء يتم قتل زلينسكي او تدمير القدرات
والاماكن التي
تدار منها اللعبه السياسيه في اوكرانيا ثم
القيادات العسكريه من الصف الاول سواء
كانت امنيه او عملياتيه تدير العمليات من
رئيس الاركان فما دون والتوسع في ضرب
الاهداف البنيه التحتيه في السابق كان
الرد على منشات الطاقه الان سيشمل منشات
الطاقه
ويمكن
محطات القطار وتتجاوزها الى المصانع هذه
الدوائر الثلاثه من الاهداف سياسي عسكري
وبنيه تحتيه داعمه للاقتصاد وبالتالي
ستكون ضربه اكثر ايلاما من الرد على تفجير
جسر كرش
اشكرك من عمان اللواء فايزه دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي وشكرا لضيفينا من
واشنطن الدكتور دونل جونسون الدبلوماسيون
الامريكي السابق في موسكو
واليكساندر بورنوف الاستاذ في معهد موسكو
للصحافه الدوليه ضيفنا من موسكو
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]